TREY: WELCOME BACK TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
DELIVERED A POWERFUL MESSAGE
TO CONGRESS THIS WEEK,
IMPLORING THE U.S. TO DO
MORE, SAYING HE NEEDS A
NO-FLY ZONE, AND ADDITIONAL
DEFENSE SYSTEMS, HOURS
LATER, PRESIDENT BIDEN
ANNOUNCED U.S. WOULD SEND
ADDITIONAL 800 MILLION
DOLLARS IN DEFENSE AID
INCLUDING STINGER MISSILES
AND DRONES AND FIREARMS.
BUT DOUBT IT WILL BE
HELPFUL, IS IT ENOUGH?
SHOULD THE WORLD'S GREATEST
SUPER POWER BE DOING EVEN
MORE?
JOINING US NOW IS HOUSE
REPUBLICAN LEADER FROM
CALIFORNIA, CONGRESSMAN
KEVIN McCARTHY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YOU WERE IN THE ROOM FOR
THAT SPEECH, TELL US YOUR
REACTION AND REACT OF THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
>> THANK YOU, TREY.
I DO WANT TO TAKE ONE MOMENT
TO HONOR MEMORY AND LIFE OF
DON YOUNG, THE DEAN OF THE
HOUSE, I KNOW YOU WORKED
CLOSELY WITH HIM, HE
REPRESENTED ALASKA FOR THREE
QUARTERS OF AMOUNT OF
THE TIME.
YES ZELENSKYY SPOKE TO USES
TO THE HOUSE.
HE DID SAY AND WHAT HE DID
NOT SAY, HE DID SAY, TO HELP
US, HE WEAVED IN THEMES OF
AMERICA, FROM 9/11 TO
PEARL HARBOR TO MARTIN
LUTHER KING IT WAS A MOVING
TALK.
HE NEVER ASKED TO SEND
AMERICAN MEN AND WOMEN TO
WAR, HE ASKED, ALLOW TO US
HAVE WEAPONS TO DEFEND
OURSELVES, THIS IS WHERE
PRESIDENT BIDEN CONTINUES TO
MAKE A MISTAKE.
NOT JUST HOW HE PULLED OUT
OF AFGHANISTAN, NOT THAT HE
SAID IN A PRESS CONFERENCE,
PRESIDENT
BIDEN IF PUTIN TOOK A LITTLE
OF UKRAINE IT WOULD BE OKAY.
HE WAS TOO SLOW IN PROVIDING
WEAPONS FOR UKRAINE TO
DEFEND ITSELF.
AND ALSO HOLDING UP THE
MiGS FROM POLAND.
WHY DENY THEM THAT?
IT IS NO DIFFERENT FROM
SENDING A STINGER OR ANY
OTHER WEAPONLY, ALLOW
THEM TO DEFEND THEMSELVES, I
ROOF IN THE HOUSE AND SENATE
THERE IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
TO ALLOW THE POLISH MiG
PLANES TO GO TO UKRAINE SO
UKRAINE CAN CREATE A NO-FLY
ZONE THEMSELVES.
TREY: YOU KNOW, KEVIN, WE
JUST SAW THE IMAGES, THEY
ARE POWERFUL, YOU ARE
SERVING IN A TOUGH TIME
WHERE BIPARTISAN IS HARD TO
COME BY, IT LOOKED TO BE A
BIPARTISAN REACTION.
IS THERE ENOUGH ON BOTH
SIDES OF AISLE TO DO MORE,
ARE THE DEMOCRATS
COMMUNICATING THAT TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN?
>> I KNOW SOME DEMOCRATS
ARE.
INSIDE THAT ROOM, ONE PLACE
THAT WAS POWERFUL,
ZELENSKYY ASKEDS TO WATCH A
VIDEO, ALMOST LIKE A CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE, BEAUTIFUL
CITIES OF UKRAINE, THEN THEY
PUT MODERN DAY VIDEO OF
WEAPONRY COMING FROM RUSSIA,
KILLING MATERNITY WARDS, THE
CHILDREN, HORRIFIC SIGNS OF
BOMBING A THEATER.
THAT WAS CLEARLY MARKED THIS
WAS FOR CHILDREN.
AND THERE WAS WANT A DRY EYE
IN THE ROOM AFTER THAT, I
THINK THERE IS A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT TO SUPPLY THE
WEAPONS TO UKRAINE TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
DIFFICULTY IS BIDEN HAS
WAITED SO LONG.
SUPPLY CHAIN IS NOT JUST
THERE YET, ROUTES TO GET IT
TO LOCATIONS, THROUGHOUT
UKRAINE, YOU HAD MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAD TO LEAVE
UKRAINE, THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN KILLED.
HORRIFICALLY.
HIS PLAN IS TO GO FURTHER,
IF HE HAD TAKEN ACT SOONER,
MAYBE PUTIN WOULD NOT HAVE
ENTERED UKRAINE, WE NEED TO
SUPPLY THEM THE WEAPONS TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
>> YOU ARE THERE, I AM NOT.
ALMOST APPEARS AS IF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS A
LITTLE YOU KNOW INVESTED IN
DIPLOMACY FOR A LITTLE BIT
TOO LONG.
WHEN YOU HAVE TROOPS MASSING
AT YOUR BORDER, NOT SURE
THAT DIPLOMACY IS WHAT YOU
NEED AS MUCH AS MILITARY
AID.
WE HAVE 30 SECONDS, YOU MAY
BE THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
WHEN THIS IS STILL GOING ON,
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
TO BIDEN IN TERMS OF HELPING
UKRAINE?
>> YOU KNOW AT THIS MOMENT
IN TIME, IT IS THE ACTIONS
YOU HAVE TAKEN BEFORE, I
WOULD CONTINUE TO HELP
UKRAINE BUT A DIFFERENT
ACTION, LOOK TO TAIWAN,
DON'T MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE
TWICE, DID NOT LET CHINA
BECOME STRONGER, SELL TAIWAN
THE WEAPONS TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES SO AMERICA IS NOT
ASKED THE QUESTION TO GO TO
WAR.
WORK, PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH
WE'VE SEEN, TIME AND AGAIN
WORKS IN THIS WORLD, YOU
HAVE UKRAINE THEY WANT TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES DON'T HAVE
THEM FIGHT WITH STICKS, GIVE
THEM WEAPONS SO THEY MAY BE
ABLE TO WIN TO DETER PUTIN
FROM MOVING FORWARD AND
BRING THE REST OF THE WORLD
TOGETHER AGAIN PUTIN.
TREY: KEVIN McCARTHY,
MINORITY LEADER FOR THE
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE